yo this is the rock kicking it with the
refugee camp and you're about to smell
what The Rock is cooking of course
yo this is strictly a club record Mike
you're not allowed to listen to it right
now you have to turn it off it says it's
strictly a club record
you're not in a club
dedicated to everybody who used to stand
outside in the cold when Flex was
spinning at the Red Zone hooded down
okay
wait so it's a Wyclef Jean song and not
a jaw I believe that makes sense
I think
oh it's about the Rock
I I cannot remember any of the cultural
context around this song such a shame
Austin is effectively not present I'm
sure he would know
as the musician of the show I think as a
musician he would know that was original
Jerry Goldsmith track
um
by the way I'm experiencing the greatest
thing in America which is Shake Shack
milkshakes it's my first Shake Shack
milkshake it's
so good big fan of chicken
hey buddy hey hey everyone we're
reporting at 8pm
which never happens hi Austin
is your audio okay
so I am still getting my [ __ ] together
here so something wrong what no no I
just I was literally working right up
until I answered the call and then I
kept working uh so the call was open and
I was revising some music so I can send
some changes on a thing tonight and then
I was like oh man I gotta open Pro Tools
and like set up my microphone and touch
it so you get to enjoy
it's okay we were talking about
um a song that the Rock is in by Wyclef
John
I don't know why Cliff Gene I love I
don't know him it doesn't matter
um what would you like to tell us about
this song as the musician I know
absolutely nothing don't believe you I
like the uh I like the
um it is nothing short of an honor that
the presumption is anything remotely
affiliated with music I'm just hey
Austin You Are music correct yeah
um yeah hello everyone and being told I
am music
I'm gonna enter the show at the start
just because it makes sense to is that
okay hi everyone welcome to playlist and
I'm a one piece I'm a video game writer
let's make the police video game
director that's also wishing you video
game composer Troy is not here
sadly he's too busy for us it happens
um but uh Mike you you done announced a
new video game recently
I did I've done well I think technically
the Walt Disney Company announced new
video games very proud to be there yes
how does that feel
I know right it's wild and there was
some cool stuff in there for sure no it
was yeah very cool very cool it was um
it's just weird because I was saying
this to someone earlier it's
it's I have literally obsessively been
worrying about leaking this game for so
long that's saying the word Tron on a
recorded podcast you guys obviously you
guys knew like what I was doing and
stuff so like I knew I knew you had my
back to like double check but I I've
actually like painstakingly listened
back to my partner
did I say the word Tron or something no
you're talking about Disney did my
eyebrow twitch when light bikes got
mentioned the closest we got oh I don't
know which episode this is in I
encourage people to go back and re-watch
uh episodes and comments and like And
subscribe on them but like the uh
there was there was specifically there's
one there's there's one moment in one of
them I remember where Austin mentions
electron Legacy and like does like a
little like you know mic like look at me
on the camera and you can spot it no one
picked up on it you know the worst one I
had I don't know if I wrote this up
since I probably have we repeat things
there was an episode where you were all
talking about God of War Ragnarok and
you said that it was like a DLC or a
shorter thing yeah like I think it's a
shorter no that's been announced and I
was just like
so it's not like I could say no at that
point in time I think you literally I
think we stopped recording and you told
me after that I said no that's not what
it is I may have yeah it was very weird
to have to sit there and be like
um yeah but for anyone who missed it
what what what's the game what is it
what's going on it's so we're doing
um
we've announced the first game we're
doing with Disney which is Tron identity
and so it's very exciting um which is
yeah it's a um
if people have played like sub service
circular quarantine circular from us or
Solitaire conspiracy it's in that kind
of scale but then just like
taken to a ridiculous level of
production value because you know Disney
um and that's been really cool and just
doing Tron and going back to Tron and
just kind of yeah nerding out over all
of that it must have it's been amazing
it's been like it's it's it's been
amazing yeah it's very
like as a fan of those movies like
massively since I was a kid it's just
it's genuinely phenomenal and also just
as a big like I'm a big Disney adult as
well so like going to d23 and announcing
stuff and having their their big there's
this talk that happens d23 where
you know they announced all the new
rides that they're working on all this
stuff and to have that talk and start
delivered by the chairman
um for of Disney for parks and whatever
um and to hear him actually plugging the
game on stage like you can come to the
theme park and experience trying or at
home you can play trauma identity just
like yeah my my little nerdy brain kind
of freaked out was that a thing that you
like listened to previous years anyway
oh yeah no that's like it's like yeah
it's like it's yeah yeah it's like being
it's like when you when you get your
first game it's like an E3 or or
whatever yeah it's a big deal
how much of the I only saw that you had
announced it
um and you've likened it obviously like
even like you just said a second ago uh
you've likened it to subsurface circular
um have you is there any more that you
revealed beyond that I'm particularly
asking when you say higher production
value I'm curious uh what
that targets because a strength of
subsurface was that it's a game that
it thrives on its limited means like it
was not a game that if you had said
imagine this but bigger budget I would
say that's like a bigger budget novel
what does that even mean you know what I
mean yeah
in this case can you even answer this
question is it is it yeah and I also I
appreciate that like both of you know
things and you're trying to work out
what we're allowed to talk about I
appreciate the diligence you're both
doing I really do appreciate it
um no it's um yeah I it's it's bigger
budget in the sense that it's um
that it's it's got you know bigger art
it takes some service over kilo
obviously takes entirely it takes place
entirely in like one train Carriage this
is more like several different
environments within a space
um lots of characters all of them
different not just robots with color
swaps you know and and you know then
then just going into music and audio and
just pushing everything because that's
the thing with Tron like
and we had this conversation super early
on it's like if you're gonna do Tron you
have to like be hitting such a visual
and Audio Level just to basically match
where the the IP is like if you like you
know Tron legacy is just like it's
incredible visually musically it's just
yeah the original still looks quite
unique to all other movies oh yeah um
like even even relative to Legacy like
the original soundtrack
yeah I haven't seen it in a really long
time
hold up
well I was chatting with Bruce box like
now we've got to play Tron the other day
yeah take a second we talked about this
a little bit Yeah there's nothing like a
flexing Shake Shack sip
so good night
oh it's a vanilla malt
so classic simple don't you know
you wanna um
you want to try the pad thai first just
to work out the Baseline that's best
yeah
yeah yeah no it's but it's cool and yeah
so that's where that's where what I mean
when I say big budget uh obviously it's
also like bigger in the sense of oh wait
no I'm not talking about like duration
and stuff but there's definitely like a
lot of story there
um so that's cool
the two most obvious places to expand
but they may also kind of
violate a core conceit of it would be if
it was all voiced and also like I guess
this wouldn't really violate the core
conceit but if you had just way more
branching content where it you don't
really it's not obvious you just have to
replay it to find it you know what I
mean like that that's that's always
definitely getting the money in a hurry
we're definitely doing the laughter so
like voice and you've you've been
through all the you've been through a
lot of this with your project right with
the musical like the the voice voice is
a nightmare for a game like this just
because you'd have to do so many
variants of everything so we've been
we're not doing 100 the same vote as us
but the but the choice thing is a big
area where we've we definitely have
pushed like with I don't know
if both of you have played subsurface
and quarantine but like subsurface
basically has one very important choice
right at the end which basically impacts
the last two minutes and that's
basically the only choice in there
quarantine's a bit more granular but not
very not very and not very readable in
the moment whereas yeah identity like
you can vary things up wildly there's
there's you know you can basically the
game can be a blood bath where everyone
gets de-rezed or it can be you know
a peaceful kind of thing of an
investigation yeah
right how what's how big is a team now
uh we're growing so the identity team is
500
yeah 500 people no identity is quite
small it's like a but we're also
Staffing up the company uh for
completely unrelated reasons
exciting stuff
I uh it's funny I remember playing
um circular and feeling like it was I
thought I'm pretty sure this is pretty
linear generally speaking like like in
terms of the overall
yeah yeah I wasn't I wasn't certain
because I I played it just the once
quarantine I then thought that's
probably I played it then so I played it
in its entirety and I remember thinking
it feels like it probably is
similarly so and then I later watched
someone's analysis on YouTube of it and
I realized it was much more branching
than I'd yeah than I had I had realized
there's such an interesting thing about
branching in general is that most
players don't even see it
so like if it's done subtly if it's done
subtly David Gator from Dragon Age who
is the creative director on this musical
that we're doing he has a great phrase
that he uses for this uh kind of thing
where you give player choice that they
don't know if there is a choice he calls
it card tricks in the dark and he's
basically like it's essentially useless
like you should the players should if
they don't be aware
yeah but I find it interesting
it's an interesting conundrum because to
me there's something really intriguing
about if imagine a subsurface type game
where you if I have two questions I can
ask you and I'm like you know hey what's
the weather outside or what'd you have
for lunch and like your answer
maybe I can even ask the one I didn't
ask as a follow-up but your answer will
be different because
it's one coming from the other and it's
it proceeds like any conversation would
and then those end up being like the
little pebbles in the Stream that cause
those ripples where that order as
seemingly innocuous as it is yields two
totally different games that you know
one ends in a bloodbath and when the
other ends in a and I mean it's kind of
the premise of the musical if then where
yeah it's like you see someone in a park
you see two different people they both
call over to you and then in a sliding
doors kind of way whichever one you say
to First divides your life into wildly
different timelines there's something
about that a game capturing that even if
you don't recognize that that's what you
don't recognize it is
I don't think so I think if players
don't know there's a choice then the
choice doesn't mean anything to them so
I think like the illusion of choices
more important in a lot of cases and
it's like that's sort of more difficult
on the internet now too because
you know some of the mass effect stuff
might not have mattered if it weren't
for the internet um the Mass Effect 3
stuff like if people felt like they had
a choice
because the game told them they did the
three explosions wouldn't have meant
anything if everyone didn't know day and
date that it was just three different
colored explosions yeah but there's also
something to be said for that like look
at look at a game like undertale where I
haven't played it 99 of the the of the I
never I fully admit I never finished the
game uh but the uh but I've I've spent a
lot of time watching People's kind of
analysis of it because it's fascinating
to me how
Toby Fox created this like infinite
Labyrinth of content for people to find
and and it's one of those things where
people keep finding things in the game
like little like and that became the
game it's like a meta game around the
game that people are finding you know
I'm sure I'm saying this wrong because
I'm not an expert on it but there's you
know there's like text files that
install in the root directory of the
game that are not accessible in game
that contain information that leads you
to this leads you to that it's one of
those where it's just so wild it's like
inscription where there's just there's
so much to it beyond the obvious and it
just keeps going and going and people
keep thinking they've found it all and
um it's just one of those where the
culture around it is quite amazing to me
well those games throughout all of that
culture though that's where those that's
why like like oh God what's the fandom
that um the Toby Fox was a big part of
the oh
um
it's like a web comic oh my goodness
I know what you're talking about and
it's
um and some of them have horns
yes yes
but the thing about the thing about
undertale is the reason that I didn't
play it
was actually because of the fandom it's
one of those few things where I was less
interested in that game because at the
time where it was very popular they were
that Phantom was very aggressive about
it being popular and I found it
off-putting um I think the reason why
the comment sections
Homestuck it is yes damn it
thank you I feel like the that that
fandom that ravenous excitement and and
aggressive engagement with it is I think
because of that we had that little
in-group like we're the ones who know
about all the cool peripheral secret
stuff and that I bring it up only as an
example of a thing that the game doesn't
tell you is there
can also be the thing that makes it
special even though
it's a harder game to do that though
like it they're like to get players but
you have to hit you know a critical mass
for sure I I'm I'm gonna tail is a
one-off too I mean it's not like you
can't you can't even treat it as like as
yeah sorry uh
I'm not running like five seconds behind
everyone else yeah carry on it's it's
done to uh it's like when a live
broadcast wants to the ability to yank
someone off the air if they'd go off the
rails I think it's Disney I think
Disney's intercepting my videos
I tend to agree with Alana that like the
visibility is the thing I think that was
a mistake we made with quarantine circle
like I think there's too many choices
you can make in quarantine circular
where you don't quite see what's going
on and um I think that's something we've
kind of done better in identity and it
is that thing of hopefully it's always
this balancing act because on the one
hand you want the story to feel like an
inevitability because that's you know
stories should only feel like they could
have gone one way it's some extent but
you also do want to show the pods not
taken it was great when we were play
testing with identity we play tested it
and we got when it was just when it was
just the story component
um and we got players who literally were
like arguing about like no that
character
dies very quickly in the game
um no no that character does this thing
and this thing and it's like that's the
thing that's really cool is where you
see that the people are arguing about
what the the canonical version of the
story is because they had their versions
well somebody else so that's cool let's
let's start that's the stuff and I don't
know I don't think people would have
similar conversations about the either
of the other circular kind of games so I
think that's that's something I'm proud
of with this one we'll see we'll see if
it could if it does that scale If people
really have that reaction but do you
ever release it bodes well I don't
remember
uh I have a release date but the public
has 2020. I've never release date I've
got it okay okay release date yeah that
counts
um but yeah no it's cool it's uh it's
it's good we've you know done the we've
done that
um we're asking everyone's wish list so
wishlist wishlist wishlist wishlist wish
list I'll leave a list please yep thank
you
um
very very excited that that must have
been cool because I feel like with this
one
I guess it would have happened with John
Wick but it feels like more with this
game than any of the other Pitbull games
you have a bunch of people who've
probably never heard of before games
suddenly be really excited about
something like it's a whole new and very
large audience because it's Disney and I
feel like that must be awesome to
experience
it's been cool there's definitely like
there's a really like really really
eager Tron audience who've wanted you
know more Tron for a little while that's
all your counterparts it's basically
you're it's just the use my people yeah
the means of this world 100 did you
watch reactions and stuff
I watched a few there's there's some
really other it's the first time we've
had kind of I was watching one earlier I
think I tweeted it the like a 20 minute
deep dive on everything that's hidden in
our screenshots wow some of which is
correct some of which isn't but I'm not
gonna say which bits are which that
stuff's cool like that's really cool to
have that audience kind of glob onto it
what's real what's interesting as well
is it's quite creepily I guess kind of
seeing some of the conversations in that
Community where like you'll have like 10
people
who are Tron fans and they'll be talking
about what they've seen of the game and
then you'll have the one Bittle fan in
that group guys guys like there's this
and this and they're like it's just a
really interesting kind of intermingling
of those orders
under a different screen name bad my
producer my yeah he's 100 posting like
50 of the stuff out there
but no it's been cool it's been cool and
and I Gotta Give it I got a good dose
and credit they've been really cool with
all this stuff we've gone for a game
that's like you know a smaller
Indie thing it's kind of wild that you
can do that with a big IP with Disney
that shouldn't be possible that's that's
weird very cool I think that's cool they
did they're doing um
they announced uh delala which is headed
out by ajuice sit next to in Boston
Studios 10 years ago where they're doing
a Mickey Mouse game
um so there's some different kind of
smaller Studios doing stuff with Disney
now it's interesting you see that uh I
think that's the same game sorry go
ahead sorry
mine's one sentence he was just gonna
say I think that's that same game that
in the
small worldness of it all is also being
scored by David housden
that's right yeah me and Dave when we me
and Dave run into each other backstage
at Disney and it was like yes
not bad yeah so David housing did the
Thomas Was Alone music so it was a nice
like that's cool we've done all right
the last 10 years have gone well that's
right that's cool there's definitely a
cool thing about working in the industry
for like over 10 years where the people
that you knew at the same time that you
started out like the people I knew who
were juniors are now like Executives at
places and it's cool to watch like I
don't know it's just a rising tide thing
it's called the watch um I was gonna
mention the
Disney Animal Crossing game that came
out this week
oh what's it called yeah uh Dream Live
Streamlight Valley it's being like
reviewed extremely positively
um so it's a nine out of ten yeah yeah
but also like people are just loving it
to the extent that I not at all a Disney
fan I'm like damn I might try this out
like it's like a Crossing between the
Sims and Animal Crossing
but you just get to have like the animal
crosses would
um be just Disney characters it was like
that's a really good idea
basically yeah it's like all the
different yeah it's a really good idea I
think it's been out for a week yeah
very very cool it looks it looks awesome
I might I might have to try it out I
totally missed this announcement I just
pulled up the steam I also missed it
until I saw like people buzzing about it
yeah
I think it was announced a while ago I
think it's it's come out this came out
yeah yeah yeah and I was like damn all
right our mutual our mutual friend John
Drake is obsessed with it
our mutual friend John Drake I have this
like it's so ridiculous because it's so
biased because he's a friend I love John
but the amount of like dope Disney games
that have come out and the way they've
changed their presentation since he
started working at Disney I'm like John
did you do this because what the [ __ ]
like it's so impressive and I keep
wanting to be like clearly it's my
goodness and he called people it's
amazing
surely but damn it's so good it's like
there's there's there's amazing it's
amazing sorry there is death it's
actually the only person who works there
just John Drake so they're remarkably
small company
there's amazingly talented people there
but but he definitely when he joined
like he definitely called up some people
myself included like there's definitely
like you can see in the in the things
that are happening like that yeah okay
yeah he went stuff no man yeah he just
he was like
Tron it's like oh that's really cool
like I mean what what a fun job actually
behind a bar I imagine his job is very
uh stressful obviously but like it seems
like he just gets to connect cool people
like that seems awesome
um yeah for anyone who doesn't know John
Drake uh
I don't know what his actual job title
is but he was previously a PlayStation
for a very long time which is how
probably a lot of us met him in the
industry
um he's wonderful
uh
he's been around yeah yeah he was he was
all that like
he was the guitar era a Guitar Hero era
I can't find his Twitter
it's giving me a bunch of uh like I got
John Drake professor of ecology at the
University of Georgia that's him that's
him Moonlight it's also him that's
awesome okay
the professor of ecology at University
of Georgia John Drake I just want to
know what he tweets about
announcing something that's going to
become a new let's make that a new
recurring kind of feature of this let's
just look up a random Twitter account to
sort of learn about someone's life
announcing some forthcoming research
positions in disease ecology and
modeling he's on brand
he's on brand
yeah professional Twitter account by the
side of it it's on the up and up
iteration of search for eight faculty
and infectious disease Dynamics all
right yeah new paper testing early
warning signs of disease reemergence and
elimination using empirically based
models great great not toxic at all
thank you John Drake We may like this
John Drake more than our John yeah
a lot of good good John drinks out there
um there's another one who president Chi
strategy officer at Drake Cooper bits of
Randomness that I find interesting for
one reason or another
it's a lot of a lot of sort of AI data
but a good John Drake's turns out
we like them all all right good stuff
um in any case when we were talking
about
uh uh
uh you know choices and and how I only
become more wait pause that really quick
because there was something I wanted to
ask that I was I uh is relevant to
something that is about to become
irrelevant so just hold that thought
um when you said that the guy like
certain people watched and analyzed
every phrase every little like pixel of
the of the trailer
do either of you know of instances
uh where that like a teaser has come out
and there's been a thing like that and
some hypothesis put forward everything
that wasn't true but the people were
like that's a damn good idea we should
we should uh think about doing something
without even being sort of legally
every single game every single game
every single every single game someone
maybe not on a massive level but someone
has every single game like someone who
has put out a trailer for like whatever
AAA game and an audience member has gone
that tree looks crap or that thing
doesn't quite work or I think that's
secretly something else and people have
fixed those things that's not what I
mean I mean it means an idea yeah if
there was like if there was like a
um
if yeah if there was like a I'm trying
to think of a good hypothetical uh but
if there was some you know implied story
beat or a character a character would be
too big that that would be two two
seismic but if it was something how
expensive is the idea how expensive is
the idea
something then that's cool yeah I have a
theory that every
um video game idea that exists somebody
is already working on somewhere
because there are so many video games
like there are just so many like
hundreds every week release on Steam it
might even be thousands at this point so
if the idea exists somebody's working on
it you just have to try to make sure you
beat Whoever has a higher budget to it
but I've never heard of that happening
but I don't doubt that it does like the
only thing remotely comparable to this
that I could think of is you remember
that game that um this this it's a solo
Dev who's either in or recently out of
University that's called sort of
symphony that's like a very kind of
music synced uh action RPG type game and
he's been repeatedly going viral on Tick
Tock because it's just it it's exactly
the kind of thing that goes well on Tick
Tock it's immediately visually
interesting it's novel uh every you know
little instance you see of it is is
clever
um it really seems like he's on to
something really promising and the
general idea is you know it's sort of
beat timed move combos that all have
sort of musical
consequences and it's very orchestral so
it's like this attack makes the strings
go and that sort of thing and
um he's been putting out these tick
tocks for a good while and then the new
Doctor Strange came out and there's this
big Showdown scene where they basically
fight exactly visually if nothing else
like like this guy's thing wow and a lot
of people went and sort of tweeted at
him like I'm pretty sure they've stole
that from you and he put out a statement
that was like well there's no question
that I released this well before that
movie came out but there's also these
movies take years especially MCU movies
where they they they knew there was
going to be a doctor strange sequel you
know during the Neolithic era like those
shits just
so so uh predetermined that but it was
one of those where it it was quite
strikingly
at least on the surface similar looking
and so it's like there is this
question of like I would have been late
I have a related well I'm a related one
I was once approached I'm gonna be very
vague and I will say this as absolutely
nothing to do with any current projects
I was once approached by a company to
work with them on something
and I declined it
and then a little while later the thing
came out and it had a very prominent
idea in it that was very similar to
something I'd done in the past and it
was very obvious that basically they'd
wanted to have me on side so they could
do the idea and when I declined doing
the thing
they did anyway how do you feel about
things like oh you
I I mean it's not great but
nothing didn't do very well so it's fine
yeah there's a composer equivalent to
that that comes up occasionally
um I don't think this has happened to me
although it may have and I just didn't
know about it but it it's very common on
uh certain types of projects to ask
several composers to effectively
audition for the job and I've talked to
friends who have auditioned not gotten
the gig and then heard things that are
strikingly similar to what was in their
audition
show up in the final score
for that right
pitch farming that's what they call it
oh yes
if you want to make something of any
kind of game or movie whatever and you
don't know what to do you go to a bunch
of clever people and you get them to
pitch for it and then you can just kind
of pick and choose the bits
sometimes send me mail obviously
unsolicited please don't do it stop
doing it it's not gonna work to Santa
Monica Studio because they can find the
address and so they just send mail there
I know my name and um yeah whoever runs
I guess like security for mail has to
try to make sure that whatever I'm being
mailed is not a pitch doc
uh I guess there's some issue with
companies receiving pitches because if
there's anything that ends up being
similar you basically like if it's a
pitch talk you have to not open yeah
um
yeah because then if there's anything
similar people could claim that it was
stolen from their pitch yeah I hope
that's happened many times like and yeah
yeah and it's happened many times and in
some cases you look at the the evidence
you know yeah this person's pitch was
sold that's that's definitely happened
but a lot of the time yeah it's just
like a vague similarity
um but yeah it's um
it's really hard to avoid it because
sometimes I just get into YouTube
comments and sometimes people like and
then make this happen and this with this
and I'm like who what
go just write this yourself it's like a
short story like we're not gonna do that
get out like it's very strange
it's a lot of as long as it doesn't have
Kratos in it as well you're legally very
safe it's all our copyrights so sounds
great there's a lot of um
there's definitely a lot of uh I think
instances of people who are convinced
that ideas might be stolen in some way
and then when you kind of take a step
back and look at it objectively you go
it's really not as original as you think
it is uh yeah I think I think a lot of
these boil down to you know like because
what to your point a second ago Alana uh
seemingly everything is in progress at
this moment
um and shorting his video game
yeah what were you gonna say by the way
when I told you hold that thought
[Applause]
you said
to be coming around you did okay that's
fair I misinterpreted
um what I was gonna mention was like no
claims of brevity ever that's fair you
shouldn't I would kick you off the
podcast for being a goddamn liar
um I have been I've already done a
podcast about it and I did to stream
about it and I've tweeted about it um
effectively Shilling but um this game
called Wayward strand just came out
today
I think
um it's by an Aussie studio called ghost
pattern it's a really small team and it
is an Aussie Studio yes
no that's like anytime I see a cool
Australian game featured in a conference
I basically immediately message them and
I'm like hey how can I help promote this
I'm actually legally
uh an Australian Ambassador for videos
I know it's very it's very corrupt now
the Australian government asked me to be
um an ambassador for video games for the
state so I like actually formally have
that title Australian Ambassador video
games but I do the state meaning like
your queensland's specific I think it's
technically yeah California by Florida
State I mean the state as an entity
uh not a specific State
um I just love the idea that there's a
different like Victoria the Victorian
Government Federal grant so I wouldn't
be surprised so this is a Victorian
Studio they're mostly got Victorian
um yeah
well you know the Australian Dev scene
at this point I was just there you are
relishing in the coffee oh God I miss it
so much and every time I go back and
everywhere has good coffee here it's
like one percent of places Australia
it's like 99 Starbucks is the Bad Coffee
in Australia
I had 26 uh coffees while I was there I
kept I kept like a photo Journal that I
was bombarding my friends with and I bet
they were all big
oh they were all amazing they were like
literally all even the bad ones were
amazing it's it's so good I don't know
what's wrong with this stupid country
anyway uh Wayward strand is
um a game that again I saw it was
Australian in a conference reached out
to them and it's also just really
interested in in it as a concept because
it does
um a lot of things that I think a lot of
game studios wish they could do but
don't often do or can't often take the
risk on which is that it is effectively
a sleep no more type uh it is very much
a play and one of the writers has
actually no video game experience an
entirely theater experience and the
other one has come through a programming
background and has a writing experience
so I think the writing stuff might have
just expanded Beyond those two but those
are the two writers I spoke to and it's
basically you're on an Airship that is
almost like a dollhouse in presentation
um there are patients as it is
technically a hospital wing for the
elderly
and everything that happens happens
regardless of of where you are or what
you're doing
so if you want to go visit one of these
patients it could be at the time that
one of the nurses is there so the
interaction will be different but
there's nothing to ever draw you there
you can really walk wherever you want at
any point in time and talk to anyone and
really do anything
again in a way that my first playthrough
of my second playthrough were completely
different
um not completely different in an epic
AAA sense of oh the outcome this person
died the twists and turns it's not
morality it's a it's a much more like
observational narrative experience where
you are walking through and talking to
these people you can follow certain
threads you heard that one of the staff
quit do you want to ask people about why
she quit and dig into that like I had
inferred that she had had a relationship
with another nurse and that's and that
ended and that's why she quit but you
could also follow questions about
white as one of the patients have a
bunch of trophies in her room
um and asks people if they know about
her history and again you would just
walk wherever you want to at any point
in time people may not be in the room
they might be in the room they might be
in the middle of eating they might kick
you out they could be in a good mood
they could be in a bad mood you know in
a completely non-linear way um again in
a way that I don't know if I can think
of any other games that have done that
quite to that extent and it's um what's
the train when I'm thinking of Austin
what's the train one for subsurface
circular the 90s no the good one the
good one the good one
train there was one where you would walk
around with a train as a detective and
it was like this running in real time I
cannot think what it was yeah so
wayward's friend also
it was right it was a rotoscoped actors
I'm gonna find this again in the
comments are lighting up
in any case I want to recommend it um
the early 90s rotoscope
Train The Lost Express The Lost Express
I was going to say flashbacks which is
an action game not at all
right go ahead
yeah the Lost Express was definitely
like a similar idea but but you're
you're right along it's the kind of game
that every game writer wants to do but
it's a very bold play so fair play to
them
um I really do recommend it and it's
again it's not like a video game that
necessarily what's going to like it
doesn't have guns and action it is you
talking to a bunch of elderly people but
I found it to be a really introspective
experience because it's such a cool
thing that video games can do and and
that plays like sleep Memoir can do
where it makes you assess why you've
made the choices that you've made like
why did I choose to talk to this person
um how interested am I actually in
anything they're saying and I think
especially when most of the characters
are sick elderly people
um like some of whom you know their
friend died one day before and you have
to move all this stuff out uh
it just really like made me think about
you know the conversations that I have
with my grandma
and how I sometimes treat it like it's a
chore because she asks me the same
questions five times because she doesn't
remember and then I never ask her any
questions about her childhood or her
life and I've never really had a game
challenge me in that kind of
introspective way so I just I really
really appreciate it um it's like very
small indie game small Studio you're not
going to see it marketed very much so
I'm here talking about it repeatedly
it's just a really unique experience and
again the kind of thing that I feel like
so many people wish they could write but
it's such a risk because
you're making a bunch of [ __ ] that
nobody's gonna see in a lot of cases um
so yeah definitely do I understand as
someone who is right now I have a
musical that has that exact situation uh
yeah yeah no I love this kind of thing
the only thing that I can think of even
remotely like this which is not the same
but the sleep no more
like that with that as the connective
thread
one of the coolest
deliveries of narrative that I remember
in recent years was fulbright's second
game
good example yeah that was great it had
that it had that theater like
voyeuristic quality where you would
replay the conversations and you could
like I loved I remember thinking
this is the kind of thing that you could
never do as a theater experience even
though it feels so much like a theater
experience where you you're like in a
room and two people come walking in
mid-conversation and you can rewind the
scene and like backtrack to where they
are and follow along that whole thing
that they were saying before they enter
the room because when you initially saw
them they were like oh shh and they like
hushed themselves when they entered the
room and saw other people and I was like
this is an unbelievably cool way to
piece together a story it's almost like
I was still pretty objective based
though like you do have to find the
correct tidbit of information to
continue it is only in these When you
mention sleep no more it it gave you
that sense of like if I go around a
corner and I look at this thing I'll see
something different than if I hadn't
which is of course the whole premise of
sleep no more
um I think it's such an undercooked
underdeveloped underexplored uh
narrative sort of mechanic if it's I
think it is because it's because it's
really hard to justify something
even see
I'd say weirdly I think the closest to a
big budget version of that we've ever
seen is is the Hitman games right they
have that similar that's true especially
certain levels in Hitman games like that
similar kind of theatrical it's just
kind of happening around here it's a bit
more approachable because they're not
narrative driven
yeah and to be clear why I actually have
something a little experience of how
tough this is because that's how
subsurface circular started subsurface
circular originally the idea was that it
was a train that was going around and
characters were kind of getting on and
off on their own schedules and you were
kind of interacting with them and
figuring it out and in the act of making
that you realize just how really [ __ ]
hard it is
um it was it was originally some service
like it was originally going to be kind
of my Odes to uh like games like the
last Express and then yeah in the act of
actually putting it together you go
actually it would be much better if the
characters got on and off the train at
the times that made sense for the story
and you just kind of find yourself
falling into the night like you know the
more comfortable kind of linear
storytelling thing yeah
um so yeah I have a lot of respect for
people who stick to their guns and go
for them yeah yeah not having the
controllers um
such a stressor and I feel like makes QA
very difficult
oh my God
[Laughter]
Austin's current uh trouble because it's
right here well it's because it's
effectively I mean I'll tell you our our
programmer on stray gods did the math on
the number of different permutations
that are substantively different and it
was Millions Austin I'm so excited about
it I'm so excited presumably they're
doing they're doing automated testing
though I would assume right
uh well you can enjoying every one of
those calls you can you can automate
testing that the logic is coherent but
but someone has to also make sure it
sounds good uh because it's a musical uh
so
um now I've seen some I've ai's control
now Austin I'm sure they can do some
music
yeah it's it is it is an interesting
um
we haven't spoken about how we feel
about it ethically but we have referred
to previously Zoom as our AI
uh extra member of the podcast Who
highlights who is speaking and when
that's true
We Appreciate You AI yeah that's
basically in the same breath as mid
journey I don't know who I feel about
similar I don't know how I feel about it
I I'm I have not um
come to a conclusion yet I just I'm
clear I'm figuring it out as with all AI
it's a very clever trick
yes it's a it's a it's it's essentially
mixing up it it doesn't have an
intentionality therefore to me it can't
produce art That's my kind of definition
it's it's mashing up stuff so it's a
randomized pursuit of something rather
than yeah so here's where the my
um
sympathies with the the more kind of
avant-garde Camp about art sort of
activates where
um
there are so many like
imagine
um
There's a garbage truck going down the
road and some garbage falls off and it
falls off in front of a very like on the
side of the road in front of a super
picturesque like beautiful Forest
and it was a hundred percent an accident
of physics
someone comes along and they simply take
a photo of that juxtaposition they have
intent
they have intent but they are documented
and they're like oh that's funny that's
interesting because that's a
juxtaposition man they took a photo but
the people who are giving the parts
today they're giving the prompts and
they're also choosing of the outputs
what they want I agree
a thing on a hill they're not they're
not saying I want to make something that
speaks to the judgmentation between
you won't get good results because the
AI won't understand I just don't I'm
just trying to between the wealthy and
the poor is
on a philosophical level though I don't
know that I see much distinction uh
because so much of art is is in the
recipient I mean like there was a famous
example a few years ago where an artist
understands what they're doing an artist
is aware and conscious of their act even
if they're doing how as reductive as it
is I don't see how the person who was
writing the text into the AI machine is
not the artist
they're not painting because they didn't
know what they were producing is that if
I go up to are they not though it's a
prompt and they're just using a tool so
if I go well if I but if I go up to
Damien Hurst and go I think you should
draw a picture of a cow
like am I the artist who made that
picture
no
no but I don't think we would argue that
he is your tool
um like whereas by definition then this
is this is actually is there an era
where people thought that using
Photoshop made you not an artist
there's still painters that would say
that they're still like hardcore like
oil paint this is a thing people people
were wrong in the past is a bad argument
for white people are right in the future
but the it no it is it is but I don't
think that's fair this particular thing
that way Photoshop is cool
photoshop's a tool but it's a tool which
allows an author to express intent and
by definition none of the AI tools
currently allow you to express a
creative intent and have it manifest
someone using Photoshop doesn't make the
art for you
it's it is literally a paintbrush these
are not paint brushes these AIS these
AIS are going off and they're randomly
mushing together essentially Google it's
Google image search but it kind of
combines the images at the end there's
no Artistry or intention doesn't seem
like it's random though
um by definition it is
responding to your prompt how is that
Rand it is it is immediately filtering
out of the infinite things it could
choose it's it's eliminating it's like
Google image search so Google image
search you put in keywords it finds
images that match what you said the own
this essentially the way most of these
like you know most of these AI artists
work is
um it's finds a bunch of images based on
your keywords and then it it's a
complicated process but essentially you
have like an AI That's randomly
generating imagery and the imagery that
looks most like some of those key pieces
gets Chosen and you know you iterate
through that few Millions I would agree
that it's red it's not
um it's not making a choice about what
it's going to draw it doesn't know what
fundamentally the AI doesn't know what a
cat is
I just can think of so many instances
yeah yeah I get that and to be clear I'm
just pushing up against it as a thought
experience because I think I also agree
I think that art requires
uh expression of imagination
uh and I don't think AI can do that but
it is interesting to say how is the
person offering the prompts not just an
artist using a very quick tool because
they have intent of expression
the best AI art that I've seen has been
stuff where an actual you know an artist
has used it to generate some texture or
like a bit of something that can like
you see people who like give it
give me some keywords it spits out
something and then they'll go over and
they'll refine so it's kind of like
you know putting an ink lot on a piece
of paper and then trying to like draw
that into an animal it's it's like it's
a nice way of roughing up the page I've
seen that work really well but then
obviously all the stuff that makes that
special and good is the is the human at
the end of it the interesting thing here
as well
um which I just want to touch on is
someone who like you know has to make
art and like has to hire people to make
art as well make them art myself is AI
legally is a mess right I mean I don't
know how I feel about it ethically I'm
not sure yet well it's well so but
legally it's a nightmare so AI because
these AIS aren't actually people people
cannot you in order to uh for IP to be
owned who owns by a person no one well
and the uh the creator of the AI
well no because the the r the iron this
is what I'm saying about the image
mashup is there are artists now who are
looking at who are finding like looking
at these AI images they're being
generating going that's the face from a
character in one of my drawings you know
that's it's it's because this thing is
not coming up with itself it's just
recommoding images it's fighting online
so there's already artists who are like
so I don't think it's been taken to
court yet but essentially this is
plagiarism it's it's it's very messy
interestingly integrated plagiarism but
this stuff can't be used to by
definition be Mass plagiarism because it
isn't capable of creating anything it is
only capable
it doesn't know what a cat is it
this podcast I would name this episode
it doesn't know what a cat is but I
should go with this
wishlist Tron
to me that exposes that uh that uh you
know copyright laws and and the nature
of
um image recognition and all that you
know is is basically going to have to
undergo some some serious
um you know Revision in order to keep up
with where that technology because
that's a very interesting I hadn't
thought about the idea that I create all
people could all tech companies could
stop stealing the art of artists that
would be the other but the thing is the
cat Genie's out of the bottle there's no
reversing course on the idea of this
sort of technology so the question is
how do you do it how do you I mean this
would be the equivalent of like you know
I tell you what the tech companies have
to hire artists to draw cats
that's the problem is if you think about
where else other than the tech sector
could you basically go and copy without
permission millions of pieces of
pre-owned copyrighted works and then
make that your com your your business I
can't as a I can't go the only thing
that I can think of sell a package of
100 Nintendo games for 10 quid here is
here is the comparison that I can think
of it's not a great one but it sort of
works
um
110 odd years ago uh the composers of
Tin Pan Alley uh the Gershwin era type
folks who were writing a lot of the hit
songs of the day would earn their living
by selling sheet music of their songs
and the phenomenon started to occur
where a singer would buy their sheet
music and then go sell out a Theater
Performing this person's music and the
composers started to realize you know
this person's earning more than I am by
playing my music so they created what
are referred to as performance royalty
organizations which were which were then
you know it it led to legislation that
governs how these rates are determined
and there's a whole thing in the US at
least it's called rate courts which set
which sort of try to determine what the
rates ought to be but basically it says
if you engage in public exhibition of
this material then the exhibitor which
in this case would be the theaters not
the performer the theater who is making
an agreement with the performer has to
pay an annual license fee and all the
music that is performed is paid out of
that annual license fee in the U.S the
three companies are called ASCAP BMI and
csac in the UK yours is called PRS it's
apra in Australia each every country in
the world has their own local
performance royalty organization that
monitors TV radio movie theaters all
that kind of stuff where music and of
course live even like restaurants
anywhere that music is being publicly
exhibited theoretically the composers
um uh and Publishers of that music will
be able to earn a royalty so it was one
of those where they realized it's not
like we want to stop people from
performing our music we want a way to be
able to kind of get in on it and they
found a way that doesn't impede it
doesn't slow the artists and the singers
out their ability to earn a living doing
it it's not a Perfect Analogy but the
idea of rather than say we should
set it up where like you have to ask
permission every single time and I need
to gatekeep it's like it's impossible
you're past that point so the question
is how do we carve out something that
says you know like if if AI can generate
it then maybe AI can track it you know
and and that you could create the
equivalent of metadata that follows it
along
nfts Austin
I mean I'm just I'm obviously no expert
and I'm just spouting off the top of my
head here but the idea of you cannot
reverse course on this stuff this
stuff's been inevitable for you the
challenge with what you're saying and
it's you're right that would be a
wonderful approach the problem is
because the AI layer exists an AI in my
opinion is there to obfuscate the fact
that you know it's a plagiaristic
process if I sell if I make a picture of
it let's stick to cats if I make a
picture of a cat using an AI
it's literally used millions of pictures
of cats to create that picture of a cat
so however much I sell that cat for the
actual return with the music thing it
works because if I'm doing a concert at
most I'm singing 10 songs by 10 people
right I'll play songs by 20 or whatever
those are it's a fairy and you would
name the songs and all that like yeah
yeah I totally I totally get why it's
it's imperfect oh no no no I'm not I'm
not cheating on it it's just it's just
trying to work out how to how to do that
with this and and also crucially as well
with tech companies they don't want to
pay for the stuff that they've already
nicked you know and you see that time
and again with
with tech companies and kind of grabbed
assets and this has happened with almost
every industry out there they don't want
to then pay for those assets
um so it'll be a tricky one to look
together
well I was to say I don't know the
solution I think you definitely are
highlighting
an Earnest problem with it I do I do
bristle at the rejection of it being at
least some form of art if even if you
were to couch it and say it's a lesser
form of Art in the way that if there was
like a separate Olympics where they're
allowed to dope the [ __ ] out of
themselves that like would be less
impressive Olympics I would watch the
hell out of that by the way like it
would be it would be like the cyborg
Olympics you know like sign me up but uh
yeah I I think because I just always go
back to the classics I I do think it can
be incorporated into one to be clear I
don't think it in itself is all but I do
think it's a tool that could be and I've
seen it used by artists really well and
it is inspiring when you see them
um it's you know it's like kit bashing
or photo montage there's a place for it
do you consider
um do you know Fountain uh of Marcel
Duchamp the sort of like the the urinals
I've got a cat using AI into one of
these and it's so bad
I don't think we need to worry about
this and let me know if that works
because it's I think that I I think the
uh the title of the episode is gonna be
uh Tron but the thumbnail is gonna be
this that was my plan was I was gonna
have a punk cat using AI but they're so
bad
you definitely don't see the using AI
part of this but I like the weird sort
of weird-eyed cat this is I think if you
typed in Tron Cat you'd probably get
something okay my uh my point being that
that you know the the Duchamp uh example
was was
um that that like that to many people
was most certainly not art because all
he did was take something someone else
made and shift its location and then
over time the general consensus has
become that shifting of location is the
artist's intent that is enough to
qualify it as art and I and I look at
that and I go you know look I it's not
the kind of art I'm interested in making
uh conceptually speaking uh but I I
understand the perspective and I think
it's thought provoking and I like
discussions that that chase down that
rabbit hole and I really don't see what
the big distinction is between something
like that and using a tool to make you
know cyberpunk cats or whatever the
newest I I think if we're
that's amazing I think I think if we're
doing like no cat whatsoever
if we're doing analogies to um our
history I I think they're actually a
better potential kind of point would be
Roy Lichtenstein would be like it's
basically Rolex inside it's the guy who
did like comic book panels as like
acrylic big paintings like took like you
know there's the classic one of like a
woman on the phone asking right yeah
yeah like you know what I'm doing now
who who got in a lot who got who
triggered an interesting debate because
obviously that artist had taken it and
done in acrylics and done it beautifully
and was selling these for you know I
think hundreds of thousands millions of
dollars but they were all basically
blown up versions of actual comic book
frames that was using someone taking
someone's art that already existed and
re-contextualizing it and you know your
comic book artist is making sense per
page right in that day and age and then
the the the uh the artist is is
obviously getting a phenomenal that's an
interesting
yeah I can see why you think there's a
closer comparison because it's I don't
know what the right answer is there
because there's definitely the the
there's definitely the part of me that's
like no that's plagiarism
so they changed it they adjusted it they
they rebuilt it the amount of things
that as a writer that you do that you
were like oh I like that thing about
that character what about that and then
you mash them together is that not the
same kind of plagiarism
even if they're not copied you've taken
a million ideas and you put them
together
which arguably no matter what
but you've done it with an intention and
you've done it using your your creating
interesting drugs of issues production
positions where I'm watching DS9 and
they start lit and and literally quote
says War what is it good for in my
opinion absolutely nothing as a line in
that show because the DS9 writers were
obsessed with putting in Easter eggs and
lines from other things in their in
their show like that's witty and funny
and interesting and done with intent
like so for me that makes it better but
then is that just is that just the
arrogance of a human assuming that an AI
couldn't come up with a good joke like I
I I like I said I I definitely have
opinions on this stuff but I also I
think like Austin it's it's definitely
too early for me to absolutely in my
opinion to a wall and say that's the
right answer because I think I also just
have this really strong knee-jerk
reaction to avoid anything that feels
like gatekeeping and say yeah because I
always just think back to
um like remember when we were working on
uh it was either on Journey or when TGC
was on flower and Kelly Santiago the
producer at that game company got into a
Twitter spat with Roger Ebert that
became the like like Hallmark of all
these kinds of discussions where uh you
know our games art and I and I gave a
number of public talks at universities
and stuff around that time where I
basically my sort of summary statement
was
um let's just argue that whatever the
great works of art whatever Benchmark
like you know the the the ceiling of the
Sistine Chapel or take take your pick of
like seminal work created by Humanity in
its entire history let's say that games
have never come even close to that level
of art let's just accept for argument's
sake that no game is even approaching
that level of art however one would
quantify it
um why are we that now in a position to
declare they also never will yeah uh and
that's the part of me that just goes
that's what it is yeah like I look at
new technologies and think yeah you know
I don't know that mid-journey qualifies
as great art nor do I know if the uh
person inputting The Prompt is an artist
but I am very hesitant to make a
declaration that something behind that
door could never be art and I'm
definitely not saying that the just to
bring It full and it's clear you're not
famously famously Tron couldn't get was
was was refused any special effects
Oscars or Awards because it was assumed
at the time that the computer did the
entire thing and that they they were
inventing literally like Innovative
amazing new technologies that will
redefine the the next 40 Years of Cinema
um but they themselves couldn't win an
Oscar because it was just a super
computer so look so I I take your point
in here for sure like no one wants to be
the wrong on the wrong side of those
those examples right no one no one wants
to be the guy who argued that Tron
wasn't an important movie in the history
of special effects and look be that
person
just stop the episode now because you
brought it home so elegantly that we're
never gonna we're never gonna uh
I I would I yeah go for it
it's not on me I'm just saying like I'm
done that was the most perfect like
segue back to home and and the episode's
done how long has already done my car
this none of this is in the episode all
right well we'll see you all next week
oh